Well, today, something
is happening in technology
that has never happened before.
Five innovation platforms
are evolving at the same time.
Never happened before.
You have to go back to the early 1900s
to see three platforms
evolving at the same time.
You might call them general-purpose
technology platforms.
Back then, it was telephone,
electricity, automobile.
Game-changing.
Well, today we have five innovation
platforms evolving at the same time.
And they're changing
growth dynamics incredibly.
So they are highly catalyzed
by artificial intelligence
as you see here.
But robotics, energy storage, AI,
blockchain technology
and multiomic sequencing.
The growth dynamics are changing
in a way, it reminds me,
I got early in the business,
the 1980s,
I was in meetings
where the going assumption was growth,
if it accelerated,
it would decay very quickly
back down to nominal GDP growth.
And that was a function of the horrors
we had been through in the '70s.
So it was very hard
to get investors to believe
that there were companies out there
that were going to help
generate productivity growth
and actually have sustained growth rates.
We get into the internet time,
and we begin this experiment with AI:
recommendation engines, predictive AI,
some people would say “pretend AI.”
And still again, after the tech
and telecom bust,
we're back in the same kind of environment
where no one believed
that growth could be sustained.
And of course, the poster child
became Amazon --
20-25 percent compound annual growth rates
over 20-25 years.
So it was possible.
And by the end of all of this,
and actually today,
many people do believe in the FAANGs
and that growth will be sustained forever.
And yet we're in another transformation.
We're into real AI.
So generative AI.
And we're also seeing these platforms,
these general-purpose technology
platforms, converge.
So AI, and I know you're hearing
a lot about it here,
according to our work, our chief futurist
Brett Winton and his team,
artificial intelligence training costs
are dropping 70 percent per year.
What used to happen
with Moore's law in two years
is now happening in six months.
We're moving from linear growth,
which was that first,
to this belief that exponential growth,
so sustained rapid growth
in the case of Amazon,
finally believe that,
in the investment community,
the FAANGs are the poster children
we're in this new world
with generative AI,
five platforms converging here.
And investors now think
that those same companies
are going to be the big
beneficiaries this time.
Now, some might, but the history
of technology is, they probably won't.
If you look at technology indices
from, you know,
20 years ago, 30 years ago,
the top 10, even in technology,
are typically not the top 10 today.
I think Microsoft has been
a very big exception to that.
So here we are.
And what does this mean?
Convergence, generative AI.
Well, it means explosive
growth opportunities.
I’m going to give you one example:
autonomous taxi platforms.
Autonomous taxi platforms
are going to be the convergence
of three of these major, general-purpose
technology platforms:
robotics,
autonomous vehicles are robots;
energy storage, they will be electric;
and artificial intelligence,
they will be powered by AI.
This one opportunity, we think,
in the next five to 10 years
is going to scale to a revenue opportunity
of eight to 10 trillion dollars,
from essentially nothing now.
Now for perspective, global GDP today,
all of global GDP today,
is not much more
than 100 trillion dollars.
And here, we're telling you,
in the next five to 10 years,
we're going to see up to 10 trillion
in gross revenues,
with the platform companies
getting half of that.
If the platform companies get
half of that, four to five trillion,
they're probably going to be worth
somewhere in the 20
to 50 trillion-dollar range.
Now, that's just one example
of convergence
and generative AI combining
to create an explosive growth opportunity.
Now, for the economy as a whole,
we believe that GDP growth
is going to accelerate.
Now we've been in an environment
of two to three percent growth
on average for years.
And if you go back in history,
the history of technology
is you get jump starts in growth
to completely new rates of change.
And very often the jump
is between three and five times
what the previous growth rate was.
We think we're in such a time now
because the artificial intelligence
and the convergence of these platforms
is going to generate
enormous productivity growth
the likes of which we have never seen.
So there are today roughly
a billion knowledge workers,
and their wages and compensation,
roughly 32 trillion dollars
around the world.
We think they're going to become
four times more productive.
And typically,
productivity gains result
in rapid growth gains
much lower than expected inflation.
And if we're right,
the GDP growth --
and I know this sounds crazy,
and most people think we’re crazy
when we say things like this --
but we really do believe that real
GDP growth around the world
is going to accelerate from that two
to three percent range
into the six to nine percent range,
and a lot of that will be
productivity-driven.
With productivity comes
tremendous wealth creation.
Productivity can end up in three places.
It can end up in profits.
It can end up in wages going up
as employees become more productive.
And we think that will happen as well.
And/or,
and it's probably all three,
lower prices, deflation.
That’s the other thing I don’t think
people are expecting out there:
deflation.
We think we're heading
into a highly deflationary period.
And all you hear today
is inflation, inflation.
And you've got monetary policy
focused on lagging indicators of inflation
and jacking interest rates up.
So yes, this is why the financial
markets are in a funk.
The Fed believes we're in
an inflation-prone economy like the '70s.
We are not.
We went through a massive
supply chain shock
in the last few years,
and we believe that is unwinding.
And that Fed policy is going to ensure
that we end up with falling prices,
which means margins are falling.
Innovation solves problems.
AI and these new technologies
will enhance margins.
So we think, during this time,
and I think we're seeing it empirically,
that these innovations
are gaining more traction today:
better, faster, cheaper,
more productive, more creative
products and services.
And so we're pretty excited
about the next few years.
And do believe that the Fed
is making a mistake,
that something out there,
we thought it was the regional
bank crisis in early March,
no,
something out there
will telegraph to the Fed,
that the fight now
is not against inflation,
and that real growth is not inflationary.
In fact, if you get real growth,
productivity-driven, real growth,
it is disinflationary if not deflationary.
So we're pretty excited
about the next five to 10 years.
And so what's the bottom line
of all of this,
if we're so excited
and think we're going to get
beyond the macro environment?
So this is what we think
is going to happen
thanks to the convergence of those five
general-purpose technology platforms.
What you see here is a chart,
and the blue part is disruptive
or transformative innovation.
Today, it is valued
in the global equity markets,
both public and private,
at roughly 13 trillion dollars.
That's a little more than 10 percent
of all global equity market valuation.
We believe that is going to scale,
thanks to the convergence
of these platforms
and the explosive growth opportunities
that they will provide,
to more than 200 trillion dollars.
That is a 40 percent compound
annual growth rate.
It's very hard to believe, I know.
In the markets, they do think
we're a little crazy.
But the building blocks
of our confidence here,
comes from our research
around these platforms.
40 percent compound
annual rate of growth
makes sense in the world
of accelerated real GDP,
very low inflation
and very high productivity.
And the number I threw out
just for autonomous taxi platforms
is in that 200 trillion.
It's somewhere,
alone, that one opportunity
is between 20 and 50 trillion dollars.
Now what's the other message
from this chart?
The other message is
that besides disruptive innovation
being a very good place to invest,
is that the other side
of disruptive innovation
is creative destruction.
And we're going to -- I just described
autonomous taxi platforms,
that is going to transform
all of transportation
and mobility completely.
The convergence
of artificial intelligence,
multiomic sequencing
and one the other technologies
underlying, CRISPR gene editing,
is going to transform health care.
We think blockchain technology
and artificial intelligence --
we did a fascinating podcast
on the convergence between those two --
is going to transform not only
the entire financial services sector,
but is going to lead to a whole new area
of property rights in the digital realm.
A lot of young people today
spend more than half
of their discretionary time online.
That's where they're interested
in staking out property rights.
So we're pretty excited
about that as well.
Many people ask me,
we have a lot of doubters out there,
which I think you probably know about,
how we maintain our conviction
in this kind of forecast.
And our conviction has not wavered.
In fact, it's increased
over the last five years,
and the numbers have grown larger
because of the breakthroughs in AI
that we didn't even expect
to happen this quickly.
The courage of our conviction
comes from our research.
First principles research,
white sheet of paper,
you know, how is this
new world going to work?
So as I say, make sure,
given all the creative destruction
that there is going to be out there,
to get on the right side of change
and hang on for the ride.
Ignore the noise.
Because truth will win out,
and the opportunities are enormous.
Thank you.
(Applause)